in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brian
and Lori Ann are with us hey guys how
are ya Dave we are so much better than
we deserve here yeah yeah well for those
of you watching at home on the video
channel or listening in Brian is a
member of our team and anytime a member
of our team gets ready to their
debt-free scream half the dad-blamed
place quits working and comes over and
watches but anyway they're all here over
here over here
watch the debt-free scream Brian you've
been with us what about four months
that's right okay so you're an old guy
now that's right a veteran okay and
works in as an account executive in the
financial wellness area smart dollar for
those of you that don't know that's a
curriculum we have for your company and
your HR team your 401k team can put this
curriculum in your company and your
company can pay for you to go through
the class I want a neat idea it's called
smart dollar and it's another heading of
financial wellness and brian is one of
the guys out there making sure that
companies know that opportunity is
available so good stuff very cool so you
guys are paid off how much depth Dave we
paid off two hundred and forty three
thousand eight hundred and thirty nine
dollars and 89 cents goodness yeah I
give or take how long did this take took
four years in five months
okay now you've been here four months so
I won't ask you about currently but what
was your income back then we started
right about 60 Lori Ann was in grad
school at the time okay
Lori Ann what's your grad degree in
speech language pathology Oh are you
doing that now not currently I'm staying
home with the kids for a little bit
full-time mom but she's starting her own
business here in the spring so okay
perfect very cool good good that's a
great business or a great field to be in
and run your own business you can
control your hours and do a lot of stuff
with that so that's very good so I'm
guessing as young as you guys are 244 a
house was involved that's old yes we had
an investment property about a hundred
eighty eight thousand of that was an
investment property that we sold about
20 grand was a car her car that we sold
she wasn't too happy about
what kind of car did he sell Laurieann
it was my Ford Edge which I really loved
at the time okay
big big sacrifice you went from a Ford
Edge to a 97 Toyota T 100 truck yes my
dad hooked us up for a little bit living
on the edge and then the rest of that
was grad school loans that we had taken
and so we kind of drew a line in the
sand and we said we got to stop adding
to this madness so we cash flowed the
last year of grad school had two babies
along the way moved here bought another
house and and we're debt-free now Wow
very cool got rid of the investment
property in the process so what happened
four years ago did you get married at
that time or what was the what was the
turning point there what was the
beginning of this story so we've been
married for ten years now and I read
your book Total Money Makeover before
that and I'd been talking to Lori Ann
about it for a while and we both had
really good examples from our parents on
on how to handle money but that didn't
prevent us from making really stupid
mistakes so we kind of I think we just
got to the point where I kept talking to
her about you know we've we've got to
stop adding to this we've got it you
know let's sell your car let's sell your
car David want us to sell you yeah which
is always a good way to persuade the
wife to get involved yeah man that was a
big turning point for me once I was
already ready for the whole thing yeah
yeah so what was the switch that flipped
Lori Ann that you said okay we got to do
something different I think just the
vision you know of what we could do I
mean he gave me your book too so that
really helped to read that and and you
know we kind of set our sights on when
we get through this like we can give
more just live differently and so I
don't know it was just very very
motivating once we finally made that
decision you know okay we're all in to
to do that and it's been like you said
there's been a lot of changes and a lot
of things you change cities have babies
finished grad school so a bit property
get rid of the edge everything I mean
medicines you've been busy for the last
four years yeah yeah so you in spite of
all of that you had a vision and you
said okay we're gonna we're gonna stay
on track some months a little faster of
progress some months no progress and we
just keep plugging along and now here
you are debt free except your home
that's right yeah well we both we both
came from the nonprofit world we both
worked for World Vision international oh
yeah
and so we've both had this heart that we
want to be in a place where we can
really make an impact and give and you
can't do that if you're if you're not
fit financially so I think that was a
big motivator for us yeah we ought to be
able to use your personal story to
convince some of these companies for
sure absolutely
I've got they've probably got employees
that look a lot like y'all used to love
hmm and you can concentrate on work when
you don't have this stuff hanging around
your neck it's pretty cool well
congratulations y'all thank you what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is I think it's just you
know getting on a plan staying motivated
listening to other debt free screams
talking with people sharing your vision
and your plan and your end goal so that
they can keep you accountable and just
surrounding yourself with people that
are encouraging and building you up and
just being really intentional to during
that time I mean thinking about okay
what do we really need when you're
having those budget meetings it was
amazing tonight you had on a budget
meeting Lori Ann what was the biggest
fight you know what you're gonna tell
you'll tell the truth I don't know I
don't think we don't really fight over
it
yeah I think our biggest financial fight
was when we first got married because in
her family her mom handled the finances
and my family my dad handle the finances
and you figured out you were both wrong
exactly it's supposed to be both of you
handling the finances I think the
hardest part for her was was letting go
of the investment property we had a
great tenant it was cash flowing and it
was like and it was our first home we
had bought it and then turned it into a
rental when we bought our second so you
thought you were on your way and really
you weren't and admitting that but
dumping that property is a big deal
exactly
yeah very cool you guys are impressive
very fun I'm honored to have you on the
team here and honored to have you in our
lobby to do your debt-free scream all
right Brian and Lori Ann Kayla and Lucas
Michaela and Lucas are how old kayla is
two and a half and Lucas is three months
old and about to fall asleep and coming
in the grandmas and grandpas are coming
into the site coming into the shot here
that's perfect
all right Brian Laurie and Kayla and
Lucas two hundred and forty-four
thousand dollars paid off in four years
making 60k a year count it down let's
hear a debt free screen to God be the
glory here we go three two one
well done you guys man that is awesome
absolutely fabulous
very well done love it love it love it
particularly our team we got our I mean
we got a young crew around here a lot of
old spots in the parking lot people
driving hoop Dee's while they're getting
out of debt a lot of people out here
working under the hood trying to get the
car started at night I mean people are
doing this stuff that work on our team
we really believe in this stuff around
here you know why because it absolutely
works you know why most people don't win
they don't bother you have to bother it
to be intentional never again as
American Express gonna call my house and
ask my wife why she would stay with a
man that won't pay his bills